bonjour à tous vous allez certainement
vous dire mais pourquoi donc comment ce
qu'il leur journal par le lancement de
la navette spatiale discovery puisque la
chose est maintenant devenu banal la
réponse est simple si chaque tir ne pose
plus de problèmes techniques et
ressemble décollage d'un avion en
revanche chaque voyage spatial est un
évènement scientifique
les six hommes d'équipage qui sont
aujourd'hui à bord de discovery vont en
effet fabriquer des médicaments en état
d'apesanteur c'est une première philippe
dumaine
avec ce premier vol du troisième modèle
de la navette spatiale américaine on
entre vraiment dans l'utilisation
industrielle de laisser paraître cette
fois on va fabriquer des médicaments
dans le cosmos est d'ailleurs le premier
passager payant de la nasa charles val
caire qui sera chargée de travail
l'espace offert et un certain nombre
davantage pour la fabrication de
médicaments
là haut du fait de la pesanteur il est
plus facile d'isoler ou de trier
certaines cellules que sur terre bien
que cette fabrication soit tenu secret
il pourrait s'agir d'un terreau peyron
ou d'une protéine lure o'chinal dont la
fabrication sur terre n'a pas donné des
résultats
des six astronautes de cette mission que
l'on voit ici lors du traditionnel
petit-déjeuner n'ont jamais volé dans
l'espace
et je dirais stick sera la deuxième
américaine a passé sept jours à bord de
la navette discovery
au cours de ce vol un gros satellite de
télécommunications militaires sera
également mis en orbite
les astronautes vont aussi tester un
immense panneau solaire dont la
puissance électrique a été
considérablement augmenté par rapport
aux anciens modèles
ces nouveaux panneaux sont décidés à
fournir l'énergie nécessaire d'une
future station orbitale